nem é esse
olá eu sou desde já muito obrigado pelo
feedback para assistir um vídeo de um
pouco assim é é a figura do fanatismo
fred aquelas unb traz agora taq taq
conseguiu escapar pessoal
fui apanhado por que não bebiam café
nunca nenhum café pode descobrir mais
coisas patinete fredes portanto fiquem
por aí
deixe-os grande apoio e como eu tinha
dito catarina foi o united states e ela
vai comprar muita coisa fascinante fred
inclusive do caixão metade sua produção
som de jesus
eu já sei que aqui tem coisas que faz
night portanto vamos abrir eu sei que
vocês também querem ver caixa
321 vamos abrir mistério surpreso 321
vai ao shopping que muita coisa é de
muita luz né só puxa o irmão já primeiro
luxo o primeiro que já aqui vai ser só o
personagem maggi conic faz net fred
sofrerei olha só como foi muito fofo
isto tem muito cuidado tá muito a sua
mãe
aí faz night at freddy's íris collection
blue chip é um cão todos netos de
coleção em plush da func mais de catorze
canalizar mais tocadores gol assim seus
óculos se você tem menos de 14 anos não
podem comprar os títulos propostos podem
incluir isso e morreram
para entender um lencinho aqui tem um
chapéu de ouro e uma coisa curto poema
expulso é que o play e costura bem feita
a maior parte dos políticos e encomendam
da net e assim vem com o instrutor de
cozinha vocês sabem para que também tem
uma etiqueta de ser vacinadas entre fred
e portanto isto é original a partida é
que eles material ex não fui eu que
matei alex
metros serão antes de ser francês a
fibra de poliéster ei é fibra de
poliéster pessoal isto é algodão
portanto não estamos a explorar as
linhas só para encolher islã plástico
fica muito feliz porque o batom é
brilhante nem muito bom está muito
gostoso estupro está fora do próximo é
que o bonita milta olha só ia faltar
muito bom o pessoal tem é que o reizinho
dos cabides porque é um coisa né
mas tem aqui um jardim ou o que é isto
ontem que pelos seus olhos já está a
desfazer o boni também tem origem em
plástico ontem que o lencinho deu também
é original supostamente tipo ea lista é
este é o luxo se mais quarto no olho
supostamente que em russo e que já é
curiosa não percebo porque se era pra
ficar mais fofo não sair tem que um
menor que o custo para caraças é canalha
tem um clássico dentro o que faz com que
isso aconteça ó
ela não dobra o poste foi nela e sempre
sempre foi assim
assim que passa em lei ian não cai não
cai espetáculo é super super durável e
isso não estraga isso nunca vai estragar
nunca até condições não estraga é e ouvi
que eu não vou usar a tesoura nené que
tal bonin eu quanto o próximo personagem
vai ser renan que ainda uma queda na
renda não vamos ver que o vulgar e eu
aposto no fox se não eu vou fingir aqui
américa looks postumamente é o fox hbo
são filme a lei é para isso que eu tenho
só depois saído ela tem aqui a língua de
fora também muito gostoso eu vim para
olhar pra mim mas não estou lá pra mim
porque porque o governo conecta ao mesmo
tempo além da câmera e coisas do youtube
é sensato espanhol ou não foi em vitória
a xuxa foi assim muito fiquei olhando
músico ter recebido quatro aqui também
diz páginas e fred isso coloque meu isto
é tudo original tudo tem 15 mil chances
também é sorana não tenha que eu posso
ficar aqui dentro nós também acho que é
preciso aplicar o chumbo é grande
portanto isto que sustenta vai entender
que o caminho também
ei eu gosto muito gosto ataque pessoal
nem no próximo dia 19
o canal para 12 ou por um fox e michael
bush que portanto vamos ver xico
primeiro foi a cara de chica tem que o
bebê dela chris leds light estamos
comendo muito bom mas não só a pontinha
olha aí e isso não falta aqui uma coisa
uma coisa uma que eu quero ficar com ela
esta e chica vamos pra próxima
duro é um solo que tem o foco aqui
também diz wagner freire chocolate ou
duas porque é tudo a mesma colégio
obviamente claro agora que possibilita
dar um foco se é capaz de ser o melhor
político está aqui meu tá muito bem
feito olha aí muito bem feito ou eu não
tenho hoje por baixo um ano agora eles
terão também não tenha plásticos são
assim mais tempo maleáveis
agora só falta uma coisa que também que
o gancho deu falta do ganso piratas
posto faltou a falta de inspiração é
quem diz fox que estava no agreste a
equipe não é não perceber o que é isso
aqui supostamente ontem que um deles e
depois tem que esta coisa eu acho que é
língua deu assim eu não sair mas tem uma
coisa permanente olha aí o foco é normal
esse é o foco e pessoal
e vamos ao último o último fight night
sempre o último personagem que também
que não está em curso
eu não sei quem isto é provavelmente um
fred sofreu acho que o chelsea chegou eu
vou chegar shannon fred e joão off do
sicredi cedo ainda nery interfones
ênfase nas flores truá num site e do
blog é exposto mim é um choro
fórum é forma chegada do fred pelo é
completamente qual fred eu não vejo
aquele francine ué não ser a cor é off é
isso ao chão forma
ontem o personagem está aqui dentro
desta caixa eo banco do lar shafiq
comigo meu deus onde isto é incrível e
pessoal fechou ontem o personagem por aí
foi o collor ou então é isso pessoal
vamos ficar com os filhos para fazerem
um estado é esta não é coleção completa
supostamente ainda tem mais luz só que
não havia na altura e por isso é treino
e não conseguiu trazer expulso no via
mais fácil se quiserem que eu trago o
resto que o encomendado à empresa
administrar digam aí nos comentários
eu já tenho uma lista de coisas pra
comprar portanto se quiserem vir mais
coisas de farmácia de fred sun walk 22
caixa surpresa tudo igual nos
comentários que eu trago e já sabem só
deixa o vosso life lá clark e passe pelo
canal de catherine uma obrigado obrigado
se entre outros dados prendas magnífica
jogar aqui porque eu estou a dar o
máximo lá e aí pessoal sabe quando você
é que tudo isto fique bem até apróxima o
faturamento subiu